in this lesson we're going to talk about
angles and angle measures and things
that they would test you on related to
angles on the act so first of all let's
look at some typical examples of some
typical diagrams that you would see on
the act first of all this is an
important one that you want to remember
from geometry when you have two parallel
lines say like l and m and those are
indicated by they'll draw little arrows
like like this not necessarily at the
ends of the line but somewhere maybe in
the middle or in between the endpoints
of the line and that tells you that the
lines are parallel they're cut by this
third line called the transversal it
transverses or cuts across those two
parallel lines and you get these eight
angles now you want to realize that
the alternate exterior angles are going
to be congruent so alternate means one
one's on the left one's on the right
exterior means that they're outside of
these two parallel lines they're on the
exterior so those are congruent one and
eight two and seven are alternate
exterior those are congruent then
there's alternate interior interior
means they're in between alternate means
one's on the right one's on the left so
four and five are the same three and six
are the same those are called alternate
interior
then you see how this forms an x here
and an x here if you were to pick up
this x and place it on this x the upper
right hand corner will match up with the
upper right hand corner so two and six
are going to be congruent upper left
upper left one and five lower left lower
left three and seven and lower right
lower right angle four and angle eight
are congruent and then
these angles here that are on the same
side and in between the two pair lines
these are going to be supplementary
these are called consecutive interior so
4 plus 6 equals 180 and 3 plus 5 equals
180. so those are some
angle relationships you want to
understand when you have two parallel
lines cut by a transversal
now this example here you can see how we
have two straight lines whenever they
cross they form an x like that the
angles that are across from each other
are going to be congruent so these are
going to be congruent and these are
going to be congruent meaning they're
equal to each other and then lastly here
we when you have a straight line like
this and you have an angle you know
splitting this up in such a way that you
have two angles that add up to a
straight angle okay straight angle is
180 degrees like a straight line these
two angles are going to be supplementary
they're going to add up to 180 degrees
so let's get into some examples see if
you can pause the video do these on your
own and we'll go through them together
so this first one
they ask us to find the
angle measure here uh for x okay and
they give us a hint they show us that
these two lines are parallel so what i
like to usually do when they're parallel
is just extend these a little bit like
this
you know extend the transversal like
and what jumps out at you is this
diagram right here
you can see that this angle and this
angle are alternate interior they're in
between one's on the left side of this
transversal one's on the right
that means they're congruent so if this
is 60 this is 60
and we know that all the angles in a
triangle add up to 180 so 60 plus 30 is
plus x equals 180 right so 90 plus x
equals 180. if we subtract 90 from both
sides you can see that x will be 90
degrees so that's x now in example two
it says find the measure of angle abd so
where is abd a b d it's this angle right
here well one thing that we know when we
have a straight line like that is that
these two angles are going to add up to
a straight angle 180 degrees so we're
just going to write an equation here 3x
minus 10
plus this angle x plus 30 equals 180
degrees so if we combine like terms we
get 4x plus 20
equals 180 we're going to subtract 20
from both sides so that gives you 4x
equals 160 and we're going to divide
both sides by 4 we get x equals 40 right
okay but it says what's the measure of
angle abd it doesn't say what's the
value of x we have to put this 40 back
in for x that's going to be 3 times 40
minus 10 so that's 120 minus 10 which is
110 degrees so that's what we're looking
for there and you got it so i hope this
helped you understand how to work with
angles better
go ahead and review these diagrams here
these are important and i'll see in the
next lesson